oh [ __ ]
it's a good night to you [ __ ]
to tune in
January 23rd the day the devil was
buried at sea
[Music]
the savage [ __ ]
the scowl eat your [ __ ] and [ __ ]
hypnotize at the same time uncle Joey
here pre Church Monday January 23rd
are you ready [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
question did you work out all weekend
are you [ __ ] technically and
physically sound for the deepness of
murky waters were going into tonight
I don't think so I got my trusted buddy
here Lisa at the king Israel and your
Cuban uncle uncle Joey
if you 18 hang up now [ __ ] we got no
time for [ __ ] education tonight
tonight's one of those nights it's
raining up it's a good night to see the
devil the devil always shows up in the
rain
[Music]
oh [ __ ] as usual we got a big bag of
stars you know how we do but we're gonna
open up with some [ __ ] wacky taffy
you know how we do just like the [ __ ]
communist [ __ ] you want to split this
one with leaf so you don't say I'm
chiseling them
[Music]
from and Izumo our [ __ ] mama leegime
oh look at these [ __ ] things these
things will [ __ ] kill you you think
the [ __ ] moon I'll send you forget
about this [ __ ] that fright do
a little hard to go tomorrow dream Black
Sabbath the rethink how they color
weather the THC is melting into the
[ __ ] pay for the understanding you
understand what we're doing here like a
[ __ ] seal you understand me
go read grandma's [ __ ] volumes
whatever you got with every ain't got
drop it alright wants for the guy next
to you yeah I see you we take one for me
[Music]
the balls on this [ __ ] a Monday night
huh on Monday nights everything on that
[ __ ] table is for you understand you
two went to this taffy and you can feel
the oil going on under your tongue you
can feel the heat in your [ __ ] heart
no fairies wear boots
hopefully your feet are sore from
marching you're [ __ ] morons you want
to March move to Russia
[Music]
oh sure we're gonna open up like six of
these cuz they did amateur this is
amateur look at this look at this look
at this look at this web of [ __ ] that
look
I pulled the coast not like this one
time with blood oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
don't know your [ __ ] ass before you
filt the animals oh Jesus Christ
five
[Music]
look at that look at that tail fecal
carefully
[Music]
how many got it two three four five six
eight seed seven that's 825 we could do
this in our [ __ ] sleep is some way
that right
seven times 125 is one it's [ __ ] 700
and 800 875 going big you might as well
do another one and doing even geez uluru
[Music]
next time check your mom I'm saying
we're eating these things like [ __ ] up
with hallo chips [ __ ] I wish you were
here I wish you were here
let's get that bond of debt ready
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yeah ferries wear boots and you gotta
believe man it's your lucky night
[ __ ] there's nothing you got
nothing but college basketball tonight
if that see your mom will cool it the
uncle Joey I'm just cleaning out this
[ __ ] bong at that Inn so we get this
party started you understand me because
we're not the mule there ain't no
[ __ ] there ain't no [ __ ] I don't
know what there ain't no it don't matter
does it [ __ ] matter it don't matter
let's do this [ __ ] here's to you
Monday night
it's a new year with new attitude the
new president get your [ __ ] together
[Laughter]
[Music]
now that [ __ ] [ __ ] bong right there
the Swedes are still little on the wet
side we're gonna [ __ ] take this to
new levels right now you know Sam and
that's it and that's that I hope you
guys got a bomb in your hand and a
bazooka and the other cuz we're going
deep to him Beto stars we look at the
wax paper from this [ __ ] thing look
at this [ __ ] you still want to live in
Iowa get on that [ __ ] bus was smoking
weed deep here even Tommy still smoking
with three [ __ ] hands somewhere
Hollywood right now
oh it's a beautiful night to do a couple
pockets and hang out with your buddies
were you looking at me don't look at
it's nothing there's nothing at Gibbs
and it's not a museum it's thoughts
they're there for a reason
there's no Museum of stars here we eat
those [ __ ] things there's no posters
and bars and us trying to be cool we eat
we don't [ __ ] around we don't look at
pictures of dick either you understand
me and I suggest you do the same what a
[ __ ] you think this tag is not washing
that dead [ __ ] somewhere vodka and I'll
[ __ ] bowl of soup with that [ __ ]
look on a [ __ ] one whatever the [ __ ]
is wrong with us
oh right now here we go [ __ ]
so I went to the doctor he said he could
give me he said son son you got this
done because smoking and tripping is all
that you do are you kidding me
when I first heard this now when I first
heard this [ __ ] Jam I almost jumped
out the [ __ ] window but I didn't have
an air condition that was there cuz
smoking and tripping is all that you do
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what once
the doctor tells you that you gotta take
a different way I got five more for you
kind of suck it's Monday night really
get the blood pumping you've been
sticking around all weekend hold the
hands eat three stars
telling me when he gets here mondays
drool with his barfing because he [ __ ]
around on the weekend they blame the
[ __ ] sushi on the [ __ ] weed
wholesale sushi Groupon and [ __ ] this is
least theme right here he's always going
through [ __ ] changes
[Music]
I feel so sad what's the matter you
[ __ ] crying about them
he's a we got a good podcast the night
dog we're going deep deep deep deep deep
and Ralphie may is getting towed Trump
up the stairs as we speak you [ __ ] you
upset Ralphie may spark and will spark
in your sparking pleased going through
changes through change ahead told you
we're gonna take into murky waters
tonight
what changes comes on it's a long
[ __ ] night here at the church and the
Voodoo but doodoo lounge you understand
me
[Music]
which thing is [ __ ] o'clock if I
gotta get a pot thing with a bigger
[ __ ] hole you understand he needs a
hole like [ __ ] like Madonna's ass or
something like that I need a hole like
that cuz this is [ __ ] killing me
I got a pump this to death eyeball this
thing I'm gonna have to get a [ __ ]
drill bit or some [ __ ] and bore bigger
hole this [ __ ] we found a way
[Music]
nice see isn't this nice we just sit
here like gentlemen right now just
[ __ ] [ __ ] amongst ourselves see no
drama no 18 people
I don't got to know somebody everybody
in this [ __ ] town you got to know
something I don't want to know nobody I
don't want to meet nobody I'm gonna
smoke with nobody I want to smoke with
you [ __ ] I want to see the
devil with you or when I have what you
do don't hang out with these [ __ ]
fake [ __ ] celebrities and she named
dick any would [ __ ] celebi's I'm a
dirty stand-up comic [ __ ] put that your
[ __ ] pipe was smoking celebrity has
[ __ ] a [ __ ] word people and the
Cuban came to swing more the [ __ ] a
dirty comic with felonies it's all I got
well I got as you [ __ ] as my
friends and that's it I don't wanna know
these [ __ ] farmers coming up here
with TMZ talking about they mate I don't
give a [ __ ] jack I just want to smoke
dope with three hands I don't do not the
only reason why do movies is for
insurance anyways I got a coupon to
twice a [ __ ] month beside that online
with those [ __ ] people I want to be
here in the bottom floor with you
[ __ ] savages you understand me smoke
that we need mushrooms and doing crazy
[ __ ] podcast and whatnot and [ __ ] you
know Sam let's fill up this bar no but
we have talked to shipping your
[ __ ] I knew carried away
[Music]
that I can still give our last goodbyes
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] monster here look
at this [ __ ] thing okay
look at this [ __ ] monster off deck
right here this thing will eat your
[ __ ] and hypnotize you Clint
look at this [ __ ] high right here of
debt dad what the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with [ __ ] we told you
roughly amazing we got stars we got
Gorilla Biscuits we got everything here
this least favorite song he's going
through changes and you thought you had
it going on so what's going on the
American people everything I write in
your world what are you thinking
did you Marge what the [ __ ] you do with
your life hey my daughter said [ __ ] you
you people that always sir
oh [ __ ] they're playing off [ __ ]
anthem oh [ __ ]
look at the best nice let's Li
stuttering at night
[Music]
that was you at 4:00 in the morning what
are you doing the [ __ ] talk when I first
met you
wait what the [ __ ] ever do a bomb I'm a
citizen
[Music]
[Music]
come back [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
pimple
yes you wanna rock it's Monday night
fuckos
[Music]
I know what's happening here maybe the
[ __ ] needle storm Sam oh [ __ ]
I see the devil
what's up Ralphie right
just trying to put the pieces together
trying to hang out with leaders [ __ ]
just trying to [ __ ] and put it together
I'm gonna go to Israel with Trump who's
gonna stop I'm shaking hands with all
the top Jews who's gonna [ __ ] with me
that shaked
all the top Jews and is not top Jews
with with paperwork with paperwork Jews
with paperwork that family wasn't they
were there at Nazareth like Jesus's
house on fire I'm talking about those
[ __ ] they show up with
paperwork and I'm saying no [ __ ]
stories no allegations they show up a
backboard cause last time you showed up
with paperwork as I'm talking about
sorry about that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's going on Ralphie maybe a truck
some [ __ ] Ralphie may starting his
residency in Vegas this Friday night I
suggest you jump on a plane [ __ ] tell
the wife to wash that [ __ ] in that
[ __ ] we're gonna see Ralphie May with
a little gamble but if I lose money
you'll be sucking dick on this trip
honey that's your anniversary present
your dirty [ __ ] mouse we made this week
yeah get out there right now book your
plane ticket go to Southwest calm right
now fly out Friday morning get your pole
suck that little young girl you want to
take you want to [ __ ] her in the ass
ask him let's go to Vegas and see
Ralphie makes you go wow you want to get
your dick sucked you gotta hang with the
big boys there's now you're gonna be in
your hometown jerking off with posters
at Chili's
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I told you [ __ ] why not
tell you earlier this morning
tonight was not a good night for you
calling today today at work you should
have told my son I'm not feeling good
plus I got a viable thing going on and
that's sitting that's dead one doing one
bong it will leak the sticks [ __ ]
clock for the gills I hate this [ __ ]
thing
[Music]
there's weeds too [ __ ] wet and I
could try it today cuz we're all [ __ ]
day
[Music]
what is
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes you did use the hairdryer what
you're about
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you gave to me
[Music]
now late now late should we turn around
your camera be on candid camera take it
to the hoop
oh [ __ ] look at them go away oh [ __ ]
look at him he's ready
[Music]
anyway go get a [ __ ] joint go stab
your wife do what you got to do we're
gonna start this podcast in about ten
minutes where you're going on
youtube.com slash see Joey slash Joey
Diaz one more time for the deaf people
youtube.com / YT /c / Joey Diaz go get a
beer wash your [ __ ] I'll give you 10
minutes and I'm gonna get this party
started right thank you very much for
joining us stay black